[ __ ] kill Chuck I think I mean he's
laying there he's not moving
honey we think he's breathing okay I
mean I was just up on the roof with
Marissa you know wearing laughing and
joking man we're having a good time I
think you told her how much she reminded
me of Sandra Bullock and how much I look
up floats
I mean nobody loved to hope floats who
knew those would be the magic words next
thing I know it closes around loosening
roof shingles up like there's no
tomorrow I mean there was kissing
touching and biting it and then somebody
starts beating I mean really will well
yeah
great when I looked up there's Chuck
yeah man what's the problem
he's like the problem dude is you're
[ __ ] my girlfriend I hope that
MercyMe like whoa you're Sonny's
girlfriend
now she was like no within it turned out
that Chuck just wishes she was this
girlfriend in actuality she's his cousin
or something and how he has these
feelings of guilt not wanting her and
then well to make a long story short he
starts crying and apparently that really
in the mood because Marissa put her
clothes back on went back down for the
window and back into the party and I'm
out there left with Chuck delivering
whining Chuck but then he starts talking
about how much of a [ __ ] he is and
maybe he should just throw himself off
the roof and for a split second I'm like
yes should throw yourself off the roof
but I don't see it you know I I say hey
you know you'll get the girl buddy you
know maybe just let your cousin huh then
I gave a nice friendly pat on the back
that real nice manly slap on the back he
looked heavy
you didn't even go sign up me who didn't
go flying off the roof